字幕: Moe Shoji
校正: Mari Arimitsu
これから 皆さんには
言葉と音楽 パフォーマーの身体と
パペットを使って
魔法の表現ツール パペットにしか
できないことをお見せしたいと思います
まず パペットとは一体何でしょうか？
生き物や
架空の生き物を模写したもの
物を擬人化したもの
つまり 簡単に言ってしまえば
人間みたいに見える
無機質な「モノ」です
でも パペットはドールとは違います
パペットは操作して
初めて表現になります
動かすために作られているので
構造はパペットは
ドールとは全く違います
では パペットにできて
舞台上の人間には
できないことは何でしょうか？
生まれる
死ぬ
飛ぶ
そして 時空のコントロール
速く動く
ストップ
スローモーション
こういうことが
パペットには簡単にできます
そして 人間の何気ない行動に
意味を見出すことができます
ただ腕を上げる
これを見た観客は この行動に
自分の人生を投影して
何か意味を見出そうとします
人間の私が手を上げるより
静寂を持ったパペットが
手を上げる方が
意味が深いような気がします
（音楽）
パペットは操作する者と
実際に出会い
対話をすることができます
（ギターの音）
（パペットの息遣い）
（パペットの速い息遣い）
（パペットが息を飲む）
こんな感じで パペットがどんなものか
わかっていただけたでしょうか？
私にとってパペットというのは
先程お伝えした通り
魔法の表現ツールのひとつです
なぜなら パペットは
無限に選択肢を持っているからです
例えば 素材
今のパペットは布、綿、紙―
針金、木で
できているんですけれども
どの身体の部分に
どの素材を使うかで
まったく違うパペットが
出来上がります
次にパペットと操作する者との関係性
この組み合わせも無限にあります
例えば パペットは自分が
パペットだと知っているのか
それとも 自分が
人間だと思っているのか
パペットは自分が何でできているかを
知っているのか
パペットと操作する者の
関係性は対等なのか
それとも パペットがボスなのか
パペットと操作する者は
今 同じ次元にいるのか
それとも
まったく違う場所にいるのか
パペットと操作する者の関係性も
無限に存在します
そして パペットは
瞬時に操作する者の
目に見えない意識の変換を
見せることができます
操作する者を消して
パペットだけが存在するように見せたり
また 操作する者を現したり
パペットと操作する側で
目に見えないものが見えてきます
パペットの世界は
人間の世界と違って
デフォルメされた
リアリティがあります
そしてパペットは操作する側に
自我を捨てることを要求します
操作する者は
パペットを操作しているのに
パペットの人生に寄り添って
共感することになります
（音楽）
それを見た者は
自分の人生をそこに投影し
また共感することになります
パペットの世界から広がる
この共感は
操作する者の潜在意識から
生まれると私は思っています
パペットは操作する者の
奥深く眠っている何かを掘り起こします
それは人類の叡智であり
時代、宗教、
人種、国境をも超える―
簡単に飛び越えるものだと思います
パペットは操作する者の内にある
言葉にならない何かを掘り起し
私たち人類の前に
そっと差し伸べるのです
（音楽）
（音楽終わり）
（拍手）